a lot of guys the limiting factor is
just like
i can't get hard and i don't have any
sexual desire it's surprising to me how
many
women will say
it's the guy who doesn't have a sexual
desire i love her i love the [ __ ] out of
my girl and i also respect her like i
love her and i love everything about her
yeah and
she's one of those gals that also looks
i happen to think unbelievable
when she's not wearing clothes
so i'll see her i'll see her and i'll be
like whoa whoa whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
is this you know and then i'm but i
again
that that's why like i want to do
testosterone i want to do trt she's like
you're not [ __ ] doing any of that
yeah not till you need to until that
comes down yeah
you seem all right but a lot of it's
like it's not i don't know if it's
testosterone a lot of it's just it it's
it's also a mindset like how much do you
like
you know how long all that it's all
about [ __ ] man yeah why are you asking
chin i'm just curious because brian's 55
and like i wouldn't have sex that often
yeah but also have you ever had issues
ever not one time you couldn't get it or
not i've never not once no that's
impressive too well that's just
something that's probably genetic yeah
i mean he knows like i've always have
energy i mean that's one thing you used
to always say because i don't know how
you have that much energy but i have a
lot of energy and if i'm not working out
the other thing is i sleep but but if i
don't work out so so if i'm just
living and i'm just hanging out and
working but i'm not working out i need
very little sleep
i can go i can i wake up after six hours
but if i'm working out i need my seven
and a half
so i haven't pretty good can you have
erectile dysfunction problems no but
it's it's happened sure yeah sure it's
happened to you too right oh yeah yeah
so i'm just surprised that brian at 55.
yeah it depends too you know you've been
an athlete for forever sometimes your
testosterone glow from that head injury
can do that there's a lot of stuff
alcohol and also just being yeah also
but by the way what other people don't
talk about also is that sometimes you
just as you get older as a man your
head's in other places
sex is not the driving factor wait do
you have kids chin like i mean you might
grow up exhausted it's not that sexy
when you have kids it's also all good
like we have it's like yeah you know we
tried and you kind of have to carve out
time for it too it's like if you leave
it to like all right we're gonna go on a
date and watch the movie and at 11 p.m
i'm supposed to like marriage is not
that romantic or sexy a lot of times
especially when we have kids yeah and
you're working all the time how long
have you been married
uh what four years but we've been
together like almost eight nine yeah a
long time it's a good run it's just
gonna it's gonna take on a different
form you know and i i think stress is a
huge part of it's discipline too your
girl looks as good as right now she ever
has
but you know it's it's
what it is
hopefully that helped chin what else you
got
i think it's going to help a lot of
younger or even like
younger guys in their 30s 40s if your
weiner don't work don't be mad man yeah
every now and then it's not going to
work for most for what 50 or 60
after you're 40 or something like that
that's it's pretty crazy you know a lot
of guys my age and younger who who have
to do the old blue chew or yeah or you
could a lot of guys i don't think that's
a function i think that's a function of
other things
everything else in your life like i said
stress is a huge percentage not the girl
but the time try telling the girl that
yeah i know they take your personal
thank you but sometimes sometimes you
just sometimes i think a lot of guys
have anxiety uh performance anxiety yeah
especially if it happens once you're
freaking out it's gonna happen again
yeah
and then and then how do you explain
that like you can get into your head
right quick that's something you have to
worry about yeah
you know that's happened that happened
to me
i didn't want to have sex with somebody
and
and i remember i was like what am i
going to do here this is a [ __ ] and
she was a smoker you didn't want to have
sex with you no i was thinking about
somebody else i was in love with who oh
break up and i and i
i she was so hot
god damn she was hot you're just i was a
young man and your wiener was like no my
dick wouldn't do it dude yeah when the
when that dick did there's nothing in
there and i got into my head yeah and
now that's even worse yeah now i'm like
holy cause you have to go completely
relaxed and like reset yourself the
moment you go okay come on come on you
can do it dude that i was it's like if i
could just have 30 seconds of the
bathroom put some newborn on it even
then yeah that'll work because now you
feel like if i don't get out there soon
you're going to knock it you know
whatever oh what am i going to do
i'm sick
and then you can be having sex and which
again i finally got it going i was
having sex and then i got him and then
he goes then he goes limp and while
you're in there
they can pretend your dick is the
biggest best thing in the world yep